I think the the remarkable thing the
moment is actually confidence has
remained very strong and whilst
confidence remains strong and interest
rates have remained low affordability in
general has been in some areas stretched
but it's been basically okay I think
history tells us the things that we
really need to worry about are to a
degree if there was a sudden rise in
interest rates yes that would be a
problem but I don't see any sign of that
anytime soon even if we did see a rise I
think the indications are that it would
be small and slow and gradual the real
concern for indebtedness comes with the
threat of unemployment and thankfully
again we've seen employment levels
remaining remarkably high and remarkably
resilient but I think that those are the
things to watch as much as the actual
interest rates and indebtedness levels
how do you assess the ability of your
customer base to withstand a rise in
interest rates well what the way that we
do it which i think now is the way that
pretty much all lenders do it is we look
at the the customers the members
affordability their income and their
outgoings and then we look at what their
mortgage payment would be but then we
also say what if interest rates went up
to say five percent or five and a half
percent would they still be able to pay
those mortgage payments and if the
answer to that is yes they meet them
when we make the loan but there have
been a lot of changes in the market over
time they've been changes on the tax
treatment particularly in the buy-to-let
sector that changes things and but and
we also now have a generation in
mortgage terms who've never seen an
interest rate increase on their mortgage
so as well as the practical maths of it
there's also a sort of emotional
question about do people know and
understand that if rates do go up
they're going to see a change in their
monthly outgoings so customers need
their hand being held more than they may
have done in the past I think so we saw
him about a year ago when there was some
speculation interest rates were going to
go up we we suddenly received a lot of
phone calls from people saying well what
exactly does that mean and those phone
calls took longer than we expected
because we were explaining to people
what's involved in how it would work if
indeed it happened and whilst we will
talk a lot about the the strength of
households themselves and their
financial resilience what about the the
banks and the other lenders themselves I
mean clearly the stress tests a far more
robust than they were say ten years ago
are you confident that you could
withstand for example a serious
turn in the housing market wealthy yes
we are we've you've seen it we the
results of all the stress tests are
available and the bank understandably
tests that scenario pretty thoroughly
and we you know we are very well
capitalized but the whole industry is in
a very very different position than it
was you know ten years ago and I think
that a lot of the lessons have been
learned of course one thing we can be
sure of is whatever happens next will be
different to the past so I'm not saying
that every everyone is prepared for
every eventuality but I do think that
the regulator the Bank of England you
know and and the financial services
sector itself is really pretty
unrecognizable from the one that was
going into the events that started to
unfold now ten years ago